from NBC HSBC downgrades Anheuser-Busch
in Bev as it deals with a Bud Light
crisis that's right their stock has been
downgraded what they're saying is yeah
this could be bad they're saying that
what Anheuser-Busch is saying about the
Bud Light crisis is not true it's worse
than they're letting on yeah
I'm having a good buy the dip and
financial advice I'm totally kidding I'm
not giving Financial advice and don't do
that don't support that this is moral
advice do not support them as a company
so here's what I think they downgraded
the stock to a hold meaning don't buy
don't sell just don't buy it that sends
a signal in my mind with the with the
bad PR and the downgrading people are
going to sell like crazy because I gotta
pass if I had a million bucks in
Anheuser-Busch or something like that or
tens of thousands of dollars I'd have
sold a long time ago I'd have been like
get me out of here and I'd buy cores I'm
not telling you what I'm saying that's
what I do core is up 20 you don't want
to miss that gravy train but now they're
downgrading it
yo Anheuser bushes is in some trouble
right should have had the foresight to
invest in the other beer stock and a lot
of people started as soon as it happened
there I bet a lot of people were like oh
we're just shorting Bud Light again not
Financial advice it's a good idea though
I bet there's a lot of people who just
became extremely wealthy this is what I
was talking about this with stocks right
I read the news all day every day how
did we not know to invest in course you
know what I mean it's like oh wait
Anheuser-Busch is taking a big hit their
Rivals are going to Skyrocket by I'm
gonna buy some and as far as uh
Anheuser-Busch goes I mean now honestly
you is not a bad idea to I mean again
not Financial advice but like you know
shorting Bud Light right now or
Anheuser-Busch right now might make you
some money it helps you know it adds to
the pressure that uh they're
experiencing because you know you get
shorts enough short Sellers and it can
really affect the car the price of stock
so if it's already on the way down I'm
sure there are people that are shorting
it currently I'm not sure it will be the
pressure it is you can find that kind of
stuff on trading View and stuff but what
if in a few months the stock is just
completely wiped out it's a penny stock
yeah because because nobody wants to
hold it because people are like I don't
know man this doesn't no one's buying it
no one wants to buy this product dude I
was laughing so hard you and I we were
talking about this in a show a little
while how uh Anheuser-Busch had sent a
bunch of complimentary cases of Bud
Light to different distributors because
they thought that that would be a way of
apologizing what we said was like no
people actually don't want to be seen
drinking it they're not no one's
concerned with Bud Light is it's too
expensive okay like people don't want to
be seen with the beer and then I saw an
article that was published the other day
I was like ah it backfired turns out
people don't want to be seen with Bud
Light
that's the issue now the viral video
from Fenway where nobody was lining up
to buy like the Bud Light stand was
completely like nobody was shopping the
beer was all there the brand is is
honestly really really damaged because
dudes are gonna look at their buddy and
be like you got the gay one that's what
they're gonna say it's the small little
joke yep and Bud Light does not have a
flavor profile but that demands You by
Bud Light they don't it don't matter
when you buy the Bud Light and your
buddy goes you're gonna suck a blah blah
blah too or something like that yeah
yeah that's it it's old but hold on
Imagine This
a young college age dude goes to a bar
with his buddies
and he wants to pick up some chicks the
question is right now
um a serious question will they how will
they feel if they're doing it with a Bud
Light
is the chick gonna be alive he's gonna
be like no I'm I'm I'm CIS you just
remember
it's it's such a small thing though
because it's just the oh what if someone
laughs it's all it is that thought right
there will change people's behavior
patterns way faster than than you know
people telling you don't do this any
amount of finger wagging if I grab this
my buddy's gonna laugh at me and
everyone at the bar or at the party in
the social setting is gonna see that I'm
the butt of the joke let me get the let
me get the course that's it's that
simple and this this is such a beautiful
thing because it shows how much more
valuable memes are and rational
arguments
I don't think you're right like like I'm
sorry but feelings care way more than
your facts it's it's just way better in
actually winning a culture War scenario
because here's the beautiful thing about
this Bud Light is Anna harris-busch is
in this hellacious position because they
because due to the corporate pressure
because they have to please all the
progressives they know they can't back
down
but they also know that they've lost the
culture War here they know that they've
now been great did this status that is
an insult to the average American and so
now they're trapped in this hard place
where any attempt to recover their image
will burn them with their corporate
Bettors with Wall Street with the
investment class but anything that they
do you know to try to recover that image
is just going to Doom them but they also
are just going to continue to Hemorrhage
money if they don't do something and
this exemplifies perfectly what you were
saying earlier about the fact that the
elite have an entirely different set of
morals that they want to push out of the
general public and often what happens is
they overestimate the degree to which
the peons are willing to buy into their
nonsense and so even though they would
say it's good and it's tolerant and it's
wonderful to celebrate the lgbtq agenda
uh of course your average person doesn't
want to and it's not just a question of
whether they're willing to let other
people do it because by drinking a Bud
Light you're saying I celebrate this
personally and people don't want to do
that yeah you know what I'm I'm sick of
y'all bigots you know what I'm gonna do
you know what I'm gonna do I am going to
produce a Bud Light Pro Bud Light Pro
Dylan Mulvaney YouTube video where we're
gonna go around and tell people please
support Del mulvani by drinking a Bud
Light and then I'm going to pay to run
it as a commercial on Facebook and
YouTube to show that Bud Light is the
beer for the LGBT community
you should do it you should see what
happens and then you know I think the
left should agree with that and say
thank you for for this promotion and
then regular people will say I'm not
going anywhere near that beer and what
we're just gonna show honest responses
from people you can get those tops that
go on the top that look like penises
that go red on the cans fit right on
there I'm just saying the last thing
Anheuser-Busch wants is for their is for
Bud Light to be the gay beer but that's
that's what it is I don't know why they
chose that for themselves but it is
seriously they want a new market they
don't want the Frat Boys to be in their
beer and they later they got rid of that
market yeah
and hey hey hey here's some advice don't
Anheuser-Busch next time don't break up
with your boyfriend until you have
another one lined up
well and again let's let's not forget
the context in which this was pushed it
was right after a transgenderous shooter
shot up a Christian School killed three
children another transgender shooter was
caught right before they went and shot
up a church and instead of saying we
stand with the Christian Community we
stand with this community that was that
was attacked we stand with this school
we're gonna donate to these people what
do they do they doubled and tripled down
on pushing the agenda of the people who
identified it with the same identity as
the shooter that just that just
solidifies that the uh that the the
boycott is the moral thing to do I still
honestly think for the average person
that the you got the gay one is going to
pay the pay the bills
that's a little too complicated to Phil
what's going to happen is the guy's
gonna be at a party he's gonna be
sitting there with this jaw hanging open
and his buddy's gonna walk in with a Bud
Light and go you're a guy yeah that's it
that's it
that's it it's like Beavis and Butthead
but would you but you ask the average
person why what would you rather have
happen would you rather have the media
and the left say you're a homophobe or
have your your buddy at the bar go
you're gay
another person fear more what does the
average person feel more where is your
power now oh you got the gay beer yeah
I've already seen that Meme too where
the guy's like drinking it and then yeah
well that's the Babylon beer with that
article it said guys drinking Cosmos
make fun of dude
that's hilarious
oh you think my peach Bellini's funny
man this is delicious that thing's gay
and it sucks bro bro's drinking Cosmos
laugh at friend ordering Bud Light
oh my God at least my Cosmo's delicious
but you know you know it's more than
that too I think part of it is that it's
just fun to be a part of something yeah
and so when someone comes in and then
they're they're like hey Bud Light We're
not gonna buy that they're all
high-fiving it's not so much that these
people probably care about Bud Light but
that they feel camaraderie unified
around making fun of something and
having a joke and then probably what
happens is the alpha dude is sitting
there and and he's with his buddies like
what do you guys want I Gotta Give me a
Bud Light like no I'm not gonna buy that
one that's the gay beer get Yingling and
then the other guy goes oh it is oh I I
think yeah you're right and then once
that guy cracks one joke they all start
cracking jokes to try and fit in and
they're just memeifying Bud Light as as
a bad brand it's over like it's already
over it's so over I said this is
actually very very funny it does really
remind me of when people were shorting
uh GameStop because it was it was a meme
but it was also the destruction of the
company
investing in GameStop when people are
trying to short it that's right because
they were harming investment firms right
yeah good investment for they put a big
investment firm out of business
and also I think uh Trump Jr and
ocasio-cortez even had common ground on
that they both tweeted the same day
about how the government should not be
privileging this investment firm they
lost fair and square yeah I know but
like talking about how Matt Gates and
AOC have worked together on some good
things it's kind of like mentioning that
sometimes Bizarro Superman will like
help someone you know it's bizarre
Superman's still kind of bad oh for sure
I'm not like hold on wait did you excuse
me do you think I'm an AOC Fanboy over
here I'm just saying like no I want to
date her Tim don't you get it like
that's why I criticize her so much oh I
thought it was because you thought she
was evil no no no people only criticize
things that they they like don't you
know that like if you criticize AOC it's
because you want to date her right if if
you have any issue with like lgbti
Lifestyles
that's the iron law of kindergarten
playgrounds that's true exactly I know
you are but what am I pulled her pick
now when when you pull her pigtails
because you want you like her oh that's
right yeah yeah so I really I guess I
just really am so in love with AOC I
mean so I guess when you make a video
about AOC you're like it's a marriage
proposal essentially basically I've only
I've only made like one or two videos
about her so I guess I've proposed her
twice I'm waiting you know they're not
getting this is modern times no one's
looking to get married they're just
looking for the Netflix and chill thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time